it is a can't miss event and it is back
for its 15th year we are talking about
the pure aloha festival and joining me
today is the ceo of vision entertainment
sean santana welcome thank you for
having us this is very exciting pure
aloha it is a staple of las vegas and
we're at a new location this year tell
us about that yeah we're at craig ranch
regional park it's the first time i've
been doing the spring event 19 years but
it's the first time ever in grass so
it's a little bit challenging we've seen
challenges that we haven't seen before
but i mean i think it's going to be a
more comfortable environment that people
can just come and not have to look for
seats and asphalt to be on the grass
just bring a blanket and just sit down
and enjoy the day oh it sounds like it's
going to be so much fun and one of the
stars of pure aloha is
the food let's talk about some of the
amazing delicacies that we can
experience there well um one thing we
pride ourselves on we don't allow
duplicate food items for our food
vendors so that way everybody gets to
have a unique experience so every single
food vendor will have something
different because hawaii is so diverse
and multicultural that you you're able
to do that but the food i mean like i my
mouth is even water right now i mean i'm
getting hungry but yeah it's going to be
a great experience i mean all these food
vendors they've been in many same food
vendors
since
ever since what's your favorite hawaiian
dish that we can experience out there
i really don't want to like choose sides
because one of the vendors might see me
and say
but i mean i think that i mean you'll
have everything go from like shave ice
to rice to i mean pineapple dough whip
to the hawaiian laula and the kalo pig
the garlic chicken i mean you have the
korean food the samoan food the hawaiian
food filipino food guam food everything
you can think of is there it's a great
experience for everybody so go hungry is
what he's saying and then you're also
going to have the the amazing retailers
that are selling things everything from
custom lays to woodwork tell us a little
bit about that oh they have everything
that you can get in hawaii plus i mean
the good thing about hawaii's kind of
shutting down so all these vendors that
were supposed to do stuff in hawaii
they're all flocking to vegas to this
event because it's a chance for them to
actually sell their products they've
been trying to get out since colvin so i
mean we got over 120 vendors food and
retail vendors i mean it's going to be a
great experience and i think everybody
comes out have a great time it is uh
such a great event the 15th annual pure
aloha fall festival in concert september
30th to october 3rd at craig ranch
regional park tickets and information
you can go to purealoha festivals.com
and we're going to bring out some of the
amazing entertainment
tickets can also be purchased on site if
you'd like to check that out and right
now let's get you a little taste of what
you can experience at pure aloha
so
and we are giving away a four pack of
tickets for the pure aloha fest you
gotta be caller eight right now call the
number on your screen ladies that was
fantastic
rocky sending it over to you